We saw in the previous
video that the outcome
of a logistic regression
model is a probability.
Often, we want to make
an actual prediction.
Should we predict
1 for poor care,
or should we predict
0 for good care?
We can convert the
probabilities to predictions
using what's called
a threshold value, t.
If the probability of poor care
is greater than this threshold
value, t, we predict
poor quality care.
But if the probability
of poor care
is less than the
threshold value,
t, then we predict
good quality care.
But what value should we
pick for the threshold, t?
The threshold value,
t, is often selected
based on which
errors are better.
You might be thinking
that making no errors
is better, which
is, of course, true.
But it's rare to have a model
that predicts perfectly,
so you're bound to
make some errors.
There are two types of errors
that a model can make --
ones where you predict
1, or poor care,
but the actual outcome is 0,
and ones where you predict 0,
or good care, but the
actual outcome is 1.
If we pick a large
threshold value t,
then we will predict
poor care rarely,
since the probability
of poor care
has to be really large to be
greater than the threshold.
This means that we will
make more errors where
we say good care, but
it's actually poor care.
This approach would detect the
patients receiving the worst
care and prioritize
them for intervention.
On the other hand, if the
threshold value, t, is small,
we predict poor care frequently,
and we predict good care
rarely.
This means that we will
make more errors where
we say poor care, but
it's actually good care.
This approach would
detect all patients
who might be
receiving poor care.
Some decision-makers
often have a preference
for one type of
error over the other,
which should influence the
threshold value they pick.
If there's no preference
between the errors,
the right threshold
to select is t = 0.5,
since it just predicts
the most likely outcome.
To make this discussion a
little more quantitative,
we use what's called a confusion
matrix or classification
matrix.
This compares the
actual outcomes
to the predicted outcomes.
The rows are labeled
with the actual outcome,
and the columns are labeled
with the predicted outcome.
Each entry of the table
gives the number of data
observations that fall
into that category.
So the number of true
negatives, or TN,
is the number of observations
that are actually
good care and for which
we predict good care.
The true positives,
or TP, is the number
of observations
that are actually
poor care and for which
we predict poor care.
These are the two types
that we get correct.
The false positives, or FP,
are the number of data points
for which we predict poor care,
but they're actually good care.
And the false negatives, or FN,
are the number of data points
for which we predict good care,
but they're actually poor care.
We can compute two
outcome measures
that help us determine what
types of errors we are making.
They're called sensitivity
and specificity.
Sensitivity is equal
to the true positives
divided by the true positives
plus the false negatives,
and measures the percentage
of actual poor care cases
that we classify correctly.
This is often called
the true positive rate.
Specificity is equal
to the true negatives
divided by the true negatives
plus the false positives,
and measures the percentage
of actual good care cases
that we classify correctly.
This is often called
the true negative rate.
A model with a higher threshold
will have a lower sensitivity
and a higher specificity.
A model with a lower threshold
will have a higher sensitivity
and a lower specificity.
Let's compute some
confusion matrices
in R using different
threshold values.
In our R console, let's make
some classification tables
using different threshold
values and the table function.
First, we'll use a
threshold value of 0.5.
So type table, and then
the first argument,
or what we want to label the
rows by, should be the true
outcome, which is
qualityTrain$PoorCare.
And then the second
argument, or what
we want to label
the columns by, will
be predictTrain,
or our predictions
from the previous
video, greater than 0.5.
This will return TRUE if our
prediction is greater than 0.5,
which means we want
to predict poor care,
and it will return FALSE if our
prediction is less than 0.5,
which means we want
to predict good care.
If you hit Enter, we get a
table where the rows are labeled
by 0 or 1, the true
outcome, and the columns
are labeled by FALSE or
TRUE, our predicted outcome.
So you can see here that for
70 cases, we predict good care
and they actually received
good care, and for 10 cases,
we predict poor care, and they
actually received poor care.
We make four mistakes
where we say poor care
and it's actually good care,
and we make 15 mistakes where
we say good care, but
it's actually poor care.
Let's compute the sensitivity,
or the true positive rate,
and the specificity, or
the true negative rate.
The sensitivity here would
be 10, our true positives,
divided by 25 the total
number of positive cases.
So we have a sensitivity of 0.4.
Our specificity here would be
70, the true negative cases,
divided by 74, the total
number of negative cases.
So our specificity
here is about 0.95.
Now, let's try
increasing the threshold.
Use the up arrow to get
back to the table command,
and change the
threshold value to 0.7.
Now, if we compute
our sensitivity,
we get a sensitivity of 8
divided by 25, which is 0.32.
And if we compute
our specificity,
we get a specificity
of 73 divided by 74,
which is about 0.99.
So by increasing the threshold,
our sensitivity went down
and our specificity went up.
Now, let's try
decreasing the threshold.
Hit the up arrow again to
get to the table function,
and change the
threshold value to 0.2.
Now, if we compute
our sensitivity,
it's 16 divided by 25, or 0.64.
And if we compute
our specificity,
it's 54 divided by
74, or about 0.73.
So with the lower threshold,
our sensitivity went up,
and our specificity went down.
But which threshold
should we pick?
Maybe 0.4 is better, or 0.6.
How do we decide?
In the next video, we'll
see a nice visualization
to help us select a threshold.